[Musique]
ça veut dire petit rêve
il était une fois dans un pays lointain
appelé
Washington Heights les rues
étaient faites de musique
[Musique]
yo voici ta chance de lui demander de sortir
maintenant hé
il y a quelque chose sur ta
chemise lisse  un diamant scintillant
il n'y a pas de raccourcis
[Musique]
ça va être des montagnes russes émotionnelles
[Musique
] c'est le moment où tu fais mieux
que moi parce que tu peux voir un avenir que
je peux
aujourd'hui c'est tout ce que nous avons donc nous ne pouvons pas nous arrêter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est temps de faire du bruit allons-y
vous avez fait tout cela vous êtes des
artistes c'est
moi c'est fou les meilleurs jours de ma vie
et j'ai construit mon petit rêve je jure
pour ce que c'est
[  Musique]
vous